the new omicron variant of the
coronavirus is leading to fresh worries
that another round of the pandemic may
be starting it's also drawing attention
to the unequal distribution of vaccines
around the world and the issue of
vaccine patents
scientists first discovered the new
variant in south africa a country where
just over 40 of the population is fully
vaccinated
a recent study showed the world's
wealthiest nations about 16 of the
global population have secured the vast
majority of vaccine doses
and that accounts for over 70 percent of
the five leading vaccines in 2021
and that's led to disparities such as
this 60 of people across the european
union are vaccinated compare that to a
mere 3.4 percent across the african
continent
more than 100 countries have agreed to a
petition before the world trade
organization to have vaccine patents
temporarily waived
the eu and germany however are opposed
to that proposal
now for more on this i'm joined by janet
minon he's a visiting senior fellow with
the aseas yusof ishaq institute in
singapore jayden it's good to have you
on the show there was supposed to be a
wto meeting on this topic in part on
this topic today it was cancelled
because of fears of that variant
to what extent is this vaccine patent
issue still a burning one or is it one
that's been more or less decided given
the opposition by some groups in some
countries
i think the
the vaccine
waiver on the
intellectual property rights
will not really make it this time even
without the meeting because the wto
works on a consensus rule and as long as
one country holds out it doesn't go
through and as you just mentioned
uh the eu has already made it very clear
that they won't be voting for the
temporary waiver
and so there's really little prospect of
it happening
so i think they have to look at
what they can do in the
immediate term uh in dealing with the
vaccine inequities
why has the eu been opposed to this
proposal to waive vaccine patents
i think the answer is quite clear i mean
there's a large number of
pharmaceutical companies that would not
be benefiting if such a waiver were to
go through
and on the other side a lot of
companies in india and south africa
would also benefit should it happen but
the problem is not
a long-term one at the moment it's
immediate access and even this way we
wouldn't have overcome that problem we
need to get the current supplies by the
current manufacturers
more equitably distributed more quickly
that's the pressing need for dealing
with the inequity and not the long-term
problem having more production in
different countries
will the new variant add more pressure
to get that done or will such efforts
falter on the same fault lines that they
have to this point
i think the new variant is put a
spotlight on the issue
i don't know if it will help solve the
problem directly it won't affect the
waiver
but you know now in some countries
vaccine hesitancy is playing its role in
limiting
uptake so i think the new variant may
reduce that we saw delta reducing that
hesitancy
but there's also all kinds of logistics
issues that need to be overcome in poor
countries you know there's cold chain
requirements even regular refrigeration
uh of vaccines is difficult in remote
parts of poor countries so i in short i
don't think it will change things very
much there are other things that need to
be done
all right jay menon is a visiting senior
fellow with the isis yusuf ishaq
institute in singapore thank you very
much
thank you also
you